werden es diese beiden mütter mit ihren
kindern schaffen aus der ukraine über
die grenze nach deutschland zu kommen es
sind verwandte aus prieros freundeskreis
dieses instagram er in und wir wollten
etwas zusammen machen schon lange
vielleicht nicht das aber jetzt kam es
so sie hat sofort gesagt ich kann hier
nicht sitzen wenn bei uns um die ecke
krieg ist ich muss helfen und nach polen
fahren und die holen und ich habe gesagt
da bin ich sofort dabei und ob sie es
schaffen würden war bei unserer abfahrt
noch gar nicht klar denn in dem gebiet
durch das sie fahren mussten fielen
bomben also jetzt ein spezial
spezialtanks vor gewinn los geht
herzlich willkommen und für euch alle
habe ich eine gute nachricht ihr könnt
auch helfen ohne nach polen zu fahren
dazu robin blase der sich für die
malteser einsetzt in der ukraine
herrscht krieg die menschen dort
brauchen unsere hilfe helfen kann man
auf ganz viele unterschiedliche art und
weise ganz viele tolle organisationen
sammeln geld unter anderem auch der
malteser hilfsdienst wenn ihr helfen
wollt hier ist ein link da könnt ihr
jetzt direkt spenden vreni frost und ich
wir mussten etwas persönlich tun und zu
wenig drängen der hilferuf aus ihrem
freundeskreis von zwei müttern mit ihren
kindern wir waren nicht mehr zu halten
wir holen jetzt
richtung pole wir sind ja sogar juden
tropfen sie unser gast manni in libyen
gefunden und jetzt nicht alle auto und
dann los
die autobahn recht frei
allerdings erreichen uns von unterwegs
keine guten nachrichten im gebiet durch
das die mütter mit ihren kindern müssen
fallen bomben aber dann gibt es dann
doch gute nachrichten
ja so in rückenlage breaking news bei
wein und zwar von der polnischen grenze
unsere geschichten sind dort jetzt
und gute nachrichten
die grenze zu überqueren schlechte
nachrichten der bus musste auf der
ukrainischen seite halten machen es
nicht rüber gefahren und jetzt ist die
fünf nicht diese waggons es geht hier um
menschlichkeit es geht hier um hilfe und
unterstützung für die die ja gar nichts
mit diesen politischen prozessen zu tun
haben die einfach nur leben wollen die
friedlich in frieden leben wollen und
nun aus ihren häusern vertrieben werden
und darum geht es bei dieser hilfe auch
es geht um die menschen das sagt stefan
ottenbruch von you to germany der link
zum mehr informationen der ist hier
unter mir dort gibt es auch mehr videos
von der hilfsaktion er hat zwei
transporter voll geladen und ist mit
freunden los allerdings sollte man
vorbereitet sein was ganz wichtig ist
die kartons am besten mit ukrainisch und
polnisch beschriften was da drin ist
weil immer sollte mal ein karton mit
einer sorte befüllt werden und sie
wollten dann auch wieder geflüchtete
zurücknehmen und in der grenzstadt
chemische stießen sie auf ein riesiges
flüchtlingslager aber auf jeden fall
haben die komplette mal mit hallen- und
mit mit diesen einkaufsläden die liegen
da überall wo man sich irgendwie
zurückziehen kann liegen da die
geflüchteten auf isomatten direkt auf
dem boden auch mit schlafsäcken von dort
aus konnten sie dann sogar zehn
geflüchtete mitnehmen allerdings wie
können die sicher sein nicht betrügern
in die hände zu fallen dann gibt es gott
sei dank einfache möglichkeiten ich
hätte ich hätte natürlich tipps für die
menschen die ein auto steigen sie
sollten foto vom auto machen sie sollten
dem foto von den leuten machen wollen
nummernschild machen und das an ihre
freunde verschicken das ist eigentlich
ganz gute absicherung ich weiß
allerdings nicht ob wir die hier über
dieses medium jetzt erreichen können
aber ich glaube das ist das mittel der
wahl um
relativ doch sehr sicher zu sein aber
christoph das ne das ist eine gute idee
weil das können können wir auch wir als
jenige die in ihren schmucken anbieten
denen dann sagen kommt ihr macht jetzt
folgendes ihr macht jetzt ein foto von
uns von dem auto von dem nummernschild
und anschnallen oder personalausweis und
dann steht dir das an eure freunde und
so weiter sozusagen als eure absicherung
dass wenn jetzt irgendwas passiert das
nachvollzogen werden kann wo ihr
geblieben seid aber es geht auch von
zuhause aus bequem vom sofa den
hilfsorganisationen können zum teil noch
mehr tun und haben eine ausgeklügelte
logistik bei den maltesern wird die
ukrainische bevölkerung sogar aus einem
versorgungslager in der ukraine versorgt
was passiert also mit den spendengeldern
mit spendengeldern können wir
lebensmittel und medikamente kaufen das
ist das was jetzt vor ort gebraucht wird
kommt das geld vor ort an die gesamte
hilfe die wir aus deutschland dorthin
bringen wird sehr genau nach bedarf in
der ukraine verteilt aber auch in den
nachbarländern in polen in ungarn in der
slowakei und rumänien haben wir malteser
hilfsdienstes mit denen stehen wir ganz
engen kontakt und bringen dort auch die
hilfe hin wo sie am meisten benötigt
wird kann ich bei der betreuung der
flüchtlinge helfen bei den maltesern
kann man sich als integrationslotse
ehrenamtlich engagieren so kann man
menschen helfen sich hier in deutschland
zu recht zu finden bei behördengängen
beim gang zum arzt bei der anmeldung in
der schule das ist jetzt unglaublich
wichtig wir müssen aber die fünf
geflüchteten erstmal am bahnhof in
lublin aufspüren denn sie haben
inzwischen einen zug dorthin erreicht es
wird spannend sehr spannend so hier am
bahnhof hat uns geholfen hier geht es
ganz viele ehrenamtlich die den
ankommenden geflüchteten helfen und
jetzt hier erstmal hinweis darauf wo wir
hin müssen genau der zug sollte um 11
uhr ankommen jetzt 21 18
[Musik]
da
ja
station
die bestechend gut freund
dann findet er den zug doch irgendwie
ja das ist wirklich richtig gut oder
also sind wir perfekt unterstützt worden
und mit einem auf wiedersehen
verabschiedet und tatsächlich sind hier
sowohl ehrenamtliche helfer innen als
auch
also hier ganz viel engagement an zeug
um 21 18 wir sind jetzt 21 7 jahren also
noch ungefähr zehn minuten
sind gespannt aufgeregt wir irren
erstmal etwas orientierungslos im
bahnhof umher aber vreni findet die
beiden mütter mit ihren kindern dann
doch
und in berlin gibt es dann zum ersten
mal seit vielen vielen tagen des bangens
und hoffens wieder etwas normalität für
die kinder
was für ein abenteuer und so schön dass
es gut ausgegangen ist alle
informationen zum spenden und selbst
aktiv werden die gibt es in der video
beschreibung hier geht es weiter mit
proud to help von den maltesern wenn ihr
mehr infos hat dann schreibt sie gerne
in die kommentare und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran